why are you such an insane person
what is it even happening anymore oh my
god it works this is amazing
alright Thai incursion mode dropped
Falcon lost is here and everybody's
cheese in it
so last week Rhys off went back and did
some patching they claimed that it
worked
we're here to show that it did not work
yeah so the original like cheese exploit
was you could you could wall hack
through downstairs and kill the APC
without any enemies like spawning on you
right that was exactly how people were
choosing it then turns out you can still
cheese it and by the way what I'm about
to show you and everybody else is not
new it's been happening all weekend long
I just wanted to see if it still work
this still does work and by the way
we're not here to ruin your parade and
piss off all the people that are
exploiting this this is obviously game
breaking and not something that should
be happening so I feel like it's the
very least we're telling a massive you
need to fix this [ __ ] yeah you know why
I'm here ty it's because I tried to do
this legitimately all weekend exactly
and the game would not match make me
into a group on PC and then when it did
it matched made me into a group that was
choosing it so so and this is what
they're doing until I can legitimately
play this have at it ty yeah so anyways
what you want to do if you're just so
getting frustrated and you're used to
getting in me by the way this is causing
a lot of dark zone disparity to like
people are just destroying people in
dark zone right now because they have so
much high-end gear and like 65% ammo
capacity or armor capacity so let's just
uh let's just go ahead and just show you
what's going on here I'm gonna replay
this on hard right now you can do this
and challenging by the way but it's
gonna be a lot easier for me to show you
on on hard so first things first you're
just gonna scroll down here like you
normally do you just started the mission
and and by the way how people figure
this [ __ ] out I had no idea there is a
way by the way to do it a lot easier
upstairs with a wallhack but that's if
you have more people I'm doing this by
myself
and this is causing a huge problem in
with with with players no one is really
happy about this book anyways what I do
is for the daily or whatever you just I
want to stun these guys with my
flashbang and then you want to get down
here and then just quickly get the hell
out of drones the drones are the bad
thing you want to get away from those
drones as fast as you possibly can okay
cool so that was actually the hard part
Aaron we we we've made it through there
okay from here you go up this stupid
ladder I'm gonna come over here and
we're playing this on PC but you can do
this on both consoles by the way it does
work I've tested it I'm probably gonna
get you banned by the way I'm sorry
Aaron
yeah they did have a press release I
don't know a day or two here saying
they're gonna start handing out
punishments yeah for people who choose
this fair warning you get some sort of
unspecified punishment yeah you may be
in deep [ __ ] anyways you want to go up
that rope you want to open this door and
that's really all you need to do open
that door and then the objective is
complete right now it says destroy the
APC so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go back downstairs here and we're
gonna go all the way back to where we
came from to where that for that second
big ladder was which is right here now
the trick here is you want to have your
I like to use a large mobile cover oh
really
yes why don't you use a small mobile I
don't honestly I don't think it matters
and by the way I what I'm about to show
you I don't exactly know I think that
should be fine I don't exactly know how
this works but let me just tell you how
I got to work okay
so come back down this ladder right here
and what you want is you want
I usually equip my pistol because it's
the it's the easiest thing to to empty
out and it has unlimited ammo so who
cares okay so the covers right there
right so if I hit a it's gonna take me
right to the cover okay so you hit a you
hold it you go straight to that ladder
you start climbing up let go of a and
now empty out your pistol in so you have
zero ammo and on this is on the last
button just hold the art the the r2
button okay and just start climbing
while you're holding our to and what
your guys gonna do climb through the
bottom of the world visible phantom
ladders yes who the hell figured this
out no idea okay cool
so now we're in here in this weird kind
of nebulous area like kind of like the
what I don't know what these are called
white rooms blue rooms like somebody
wants to give yeah there's a trade with
the hobo or whatever like maybe this is
a part of the game they'll expand upon
who knows anyways it doesn't really
matter at this point right so you're
gonna come all the way over here until
you see the APC now that's where it is
on the other side of this wall so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go to my
inventory by the way this always helps
if you have really high skill power we
don't right now just for the sake of
this video though I wanted to make sure
we had more hit points to get to that
first part but what I want to do is I
want to come here and then you want to
equip your explosive sticky bomb like
that and then you want to that right
there's your APC right so watch I can
just do that I can explode it boom
92 damage right and now I can just sit
here all day wait for that thing to
recharge and we can spend about you know
well because they don't have a teammate
or a squad of four this is probably
going to take an hour if we actually
showed you this but that's all you can
do how do you how do you get your loot
once you once you've killed it so what
we discovered is you can go back and get
your loot all you do is fast travel once
you kill the APC you'll get your week
your weekly reward if this is a weekly
and it works on challenging or hard and
then you can fast travel to the
beginning of this level and go back down
the sewer and just go right through the
level and you can get your your drop so
we're talking like two 42 or fourteen
depending on what difficulty you play
the set but this is the [ __ ] that
massive needs to fix this is what's
causing a lot of ruckus you go to the
reddit it's insane and and yeah because
like all there are they're just people
doing this non-stop man there you go
like destiny all over again where it's
not a PvP or PvE it's PVD player verse
develop yeah you can do other things
here by the way with a squad you can
like equip I think it's uh yeah it's
ammo cache so that will make you
recover your skill faster and then you
can also heal each other with with
overdose and you know healing target
makes like if you kill your teammates
that also makes your skill or power a
little bit faster as well so that's it
folks that's what the cheese is all
about cool um well you know have fun not
getting banned yeah again there's an
easier way to do this where you can like
wallhack up there but I just want to
show you this for the sake of just us
being by ourselves at this point but
yeah do it at your own risk and massive
please let's uh let's get this fixed